what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and and you
already know guys yesterday I went to a
feminist event okay I went to a feminist
event and I wore my women shouldn't vote
t-shirt needless to say I was greeted
with a lot of warmth
loving amazing welcome they all just
said Pearl you're so awesome and amazing
um so tune into the footage that should
be dropped later this week and get
yourself a woman shouldn't vote t-shirt
today the link is in the description
guys I'm telling you they love the
shirts women will just come up to you
left and right and today's theme is
really going to talk about how when
women make decisions
typically they find someone else to
Blink whoever is like the closest person
to blame I don't know why we're like
this it's just we just tend to do it so
Lana Rhodes is an ex-porn star and I
guess a couple of years ago this girl
was really big on the porn sites I think
she's got some other videos out there I
don't I don't really know not my thing
um but it's interesting to see like what
path her life has gone down because you
know she was the hottest thing in porn I
guess I think she did it for a year and
then she transitioned into social media
which is a really common like path that
I see a lot of these like porn stars
make and it's really interesting because
you know she there's clips of her that
go viral about her regretting porn but
she still kind of chooses to be a public
figure and use her porn name
so that's a little bit confusing to me
but there is a clip of her going viral
um talking about her regrets in the porn
industry pull it up they say smart
people learn from other people's
mistakes schools learn from their own is
very much a fool in most of my decisions
even with all the success that you've
had your incredible mother now business
woman you're working with Playboy you
still look back on that and you still
feel ashamed yeah I don't like the fact
that people can see me naked on the
Internet or I can see those things
happening to me I think that it's gross
that is crazy that you can can build
this whole life and you still feel
ashamed I mean I'm I'm proud of myself
and what I've done and and I wouldn't
take anything back however it's not like
I love I like the idea that people can
view that of me I personally those
videos make me want to throw up okay a
couple things why don't porn stars just
admit they would take it back
I mean hell I think everyone can look
back at their lives and think of a
couple things that we could take back I
just I get so confused as to like why we
don't just say yeah I would take it back
so a couple things I am I do appreciate
that she's being honest because a lot of
porn stars are not honest about the
consequences of their actions and they
kind of act like there's no consequences
you can go into porn and you'll just
have a happy life after and it's really
just not the case you know
she's a successful businesswoman but
would she be a successful businesswoman
without porn getting her to be well
known I have a hard time believing it
and it's interesting to say she's
learned from her mistakes she kind of
went on this like hoe we call it like
the ho apology tour
um which is fine right at least they're
being honest but you know it just makes
me question then you go and get pregnant
by an NBA player allegedly
not your single mom it's kind of like
that's why men I'm telling you guys this
is why men really don't uh believe women
when we do these apology tours because a
lot of times and then you'll you'll see
like Mia Khalifa did the whole apology
tour then she started only fans again
and they always seem to blame it on like
the predatory men rather than their
desire for attention
you know and and I I've yet to really
see a porn star take accountability and
say yeah I just wanted more and more
attention and I would do anything to get
it and I now I'm paying the price it's
always well I was coerced I was
coaxed I was abused whatever whatever
but this is the problem when we don't
have gold standard women raising our
daughters anymore so guys are you
feeling unsure about your finances these
days look you're not alone this is why
noble gold Investments is here to help
just hear it straight from the folks
that they have helped the noble crew
walked me through everything no stress
and with their help I can finally sleep
easy at night and now this month Noble
gold Investments is handing out free 5
ounce silver America the Beautiful coins
if you qualify for an IRA invest in gold
and silver with Noble gold Investments
go to noblegoldinvestments.com now
noblegoldinvestments.com it's the only
gold company that I trust
but back to back to the topic I mean
this is why single mother homes are so
detrimental to society I mean they and
and weak fathers you know you're
supposed to have a father that would
literally disown you if you would ever
do something like that but well with the
dynamic we we continually see is these
weak fathers that allow for anything to
go on and women putting accountability
on the men
um and another example of accountability
being put on the men is I see women go
after these Superstar celebrity men and
they're [__] and they just typically
cry later so so the Matrix is now coming
after Russell Brand the comedian actor
podcaster who has been loved by many for
years and now after his whole career you
know everyone loves him now
after 20 years now he's a rapist sexual
assaultist even though there's no police
report let's check it out are some very
serious allegations that I absolutely
refute
these allegations pertain to the time
when I was working in the mainstream
when I was in the newspapers all the
time when I was in the movies and as
I've written about extensively in my
books I was very very promiscuous now
during that time of promiscuity the
relationships I had were absolutely
always consensual I was always
transparent about that then almost too
transparent and I'm being transparent
about it now as well and to see that
transparency metastasized into something
criminal that I absolutely deny makes me
question is there another agenda at play
particularly when we've seen coordinated
media attacks before like with Joe Rogan
when he dared to take a medicine that
the mainstream media didn't approve of
and we saw a Spate of headlines from
media Outlets across the world using the
same language I'm aware that you guys
have been saying in the comments for a
while watch out Russell they're coming
for you you're getting too close to the
truth Russell Brand did not kill himself
I know that a year ago there was a Spate
of Articles Russell Brown's a conspiracy
theorist Russell Brand's right wing I'm
aware of news media making phone calls
sending letters to people I know for
ages and ages it's been clear to me or
at least it feels to me like there's a
serious and concerted agenda to control
these kind of spaces and these kind of
voices and I mean my voice along with
your voice I don't mind them using my
books and my stand up to talk about my
promiscuous consensual conduct in the
past what I seriously refute are these
very very serious criminal allegations
also it's worth mentioning that there
are witnesses whose evidence directly
contradicts the narratives that these
two mainstream media Outlets are trying
to construct apparently in what seems to
me to be a coordinated attack now I
don't want to get into this any further
because of the serious nature of the
allegations but I feel like I'm being
attacked and plainly they are working
very closely together we are obviously
going to look into this matter because
it's very very serious in the meantime I
want you to stay close stay awake but
more important than any of that if you
can please stay free
okay so I have a couple questions where
is the police report
why would you wait
five ten years to come out and why would
a man that is Rich and Famous need to
rape anybody I mean like guys let's just
put two and two together
men like Drake have women throwing
hundreds of bras on stage
why would a guy
need to to assault or rape anybody
in order to get sex that's having it
thrown at him 24 7. this is the
equivalent okay this is the equivalent
of me being a billionaire and getting
accused of robbing a bank I
I don't believe this this is the same
thing they did the date this is the same
thing they've done to Noah Clark this is
the same thing that they've done to
comedian politician
basically any guy that decides to tell
the truth and go against the mainstream
narrative they they throw all these
allegations at and I think we need to
get to a point where I I mean guys we
have to be a bit skeptical that rich
famous men are are raping women like
that I mean this really doesn't make any
sense and my question is what is assault
what we need we need to get clear
definitions so we can determine if this
stuff happened but now now we say
consent what is consent what's not
consent and it just gets really
confusing to the general public so you
know I I we can wait till the facts come
out of the case but I just I have a hard
time believing that any guy that is Rich
and Famous really needs to rape women
like that sorry for being the one to say
it but that's just my opinion on it so
and and what I see guys and this is just
general Trends is women really like
typically what happens is they come out
years later
they come out and my question is to
those women why would you wait years
okay I'll give you a week I'll give you
two weeks I'll even maybe give you a
month
but
uh 10 years later now he's an abuser 10
years later now he's a rapist
um and until I see police reports and
substantial evidence proving these
claims I I just and I think it's
actually wrong and I think the news
outlets should be held accountable for
reporting on stories with zero evidence
I think they should be held accountable
for labeling a guy a criminal without
telling two sides of the story and guys
you know this is what happened to
Stephen Crowder in front of our eyes you
know I'm going to be doing a stream on
him either tonight or tomorrow
very similar it's on the right and the
left
okay so you know back to women not
taking accountability for their actions
you know so adam22 has the show called
no jumper so as you guys know I've been
going back and forth on Twitter with
adam22. he'll call me single and
childless I'll say you pimped out your
wife you know what you know what it is
so anyway so
what adam22 does is he he has
interviewed many porn stars rappers
entertainers on his show and overall
like I would say it's very high
production his team's very professional
and even even I was on there okay and
so but what I what I wanted to point out
was Adam 22 called me a misogynist okay
remember that remember that I Pearl am a
misogynist okay yet this is some of the
consequences of coming on his platform
so let's play play the clip on my
birthday I was getting in a hotel room
they all pulled up and I sucked it down
the whole team seven seven basketball
players in a row how was that swallowed
all of them yeah do you look back at
this as a positive memory yeah
a few moments later I'm not proud of
that story anymore I'm in you know
reformed are you reformed now now she
reformed three years ago she's not proud
of that story but I'm also not ashamed
and like people can't come in my DMs and
like make me feel horrible when I was 21
I've been living my best life that was
three years ago when she was 21. it was
done and I've learned from that and I
honestly think it's a funny story and
you still think it's funny if you feel
some type of way about it no matter how
you try to sugarcoat it because if you
didn't build a certain type of way about
it you would have made this video okay
so
now mind you this isn't Adam's fault
this is that chick's fault okay that's
that's the consequences of her own
actions but you know following his life
path why do you think she regrets it now
why do you think she regrets telling
that story now
oh because there's consequences because
the stuff he pushes leads women to be
single and childless
I mean the stuff he put not not only
that the stuff he pushes really leads
women to destruction you think she's
going to get married have kids you think
what's her future now it's really either
porn or only fan so who is the real
misogynist the one that's telling you
the truth and being honest with you
about the consequences or the one that's
pushing a lifestyle where you suck off
seven dudes in one night like this is
this is crazy guys and this is the
problem with the left you know they guys
themselves as non-judgmental loving Etc
but who who really cares about you the
the people that are telling you what you
want to hear the people telling you the
truth and and that's the bot and that's
the bottom line of the matter is that we
need to Value honesty Above All Else
we need we need to be honest and the
truth of the matter is doing that is is
you're done there there's no light at
the end of the tunnel no one's really
gonna take you seriously after that and
you know it's her own fault for doing it
but the lifestyle he promotes and
honestly he assists women in doing this
guy assists women in joining the porn
industry he manages them and look it I
mean it's legal but
I mean who's the real misogynist
the one helping assisting women and
making decisions that will ruin their
prospects of having a marriage and a
family
um or the one
that's telling them the truth
and you know you could call me what you
want but at least I'm honest at least
I'm honest so
you know and this is this is kind of the
trend that the guys have seen where at
21 the chicks are doing this wild crazy
stuff and then at 25 all of a sudden
they're reformed and ladies you know God
can forgive you but men don't have to
and I want you to really hear this you
know God can forgive you God will
forgive you but men don't have to and
the truth of the matter is your actions
are a direct reflection of the husband
you get so if if you choose to do this
it's probably going to be none at all
and and the more you do the the less
likely it is you're really going to end
up with anyone and that's the truth of
the matter so be careful what you do
don't put a bunch of [__] like that on
the internet and guys I mean I don't I
never thought I'd have to be in a world
well where I'd have to say don't suck
seven guys off in one night
I mean what
I mean that's don't have sex on camera
you know and this is why you need strong
masculine fathers women should know
they'll be disowned they would
villainize their dads for not accepting
them being gay not accepting them doing
ho [__] not accepting them leaving the
church that's what they're supposed to
do that's what fathers are meant to do
you guys want masculine men but then you
shame them for doing the very thing that
makes them masculine protection they're
supposed to protect you but we live in a
world where the media and the messaging
is telling women to go down this crazy
crazy route and this is the thing I'm so
tired of these men simping and just
telling us what we want to hear ladies
like we need to be done being pandered
to I'm so done with it I don't want to
be pandered to anymore and you know
there's a woman that was asking the
general public to Pander to her because
she was some fatty so some fatty with a
social media following uh tried to go
horseback riding and she was over 240
pounds which is fat as [__] like it's
it's sorry guys fat as hell fat as heck
like fat
I'm six foot I'm not over 200 like
like the average woman's like five five
six
and you're 240 pounds
okay but let's play the clip so this
tick tocker wanted to go horseback
riding and she contacts a horse ranch
and schedules a ride and she gets there
and apparently they wouldn't let her
ride because there's a weight limit and
she happens to weigh more than the 240
pound limit and according to her they
were rude to her about it while turning
her away they told me that I could not
go on the horse because I was too big
but they didn't tell me that in the
beginning so in response she posts this
Tick Tock about it shout out to deep
Hollow Ranch for making me leave because
I weigh over 240. but she's got a big
audience so the video blows up pretty
quickly and gets several million views
and her audience sees the video and they
get mad and they start review bombing
the ranch on Yelp this horse ranch is
terrible I would never ride horses here
horses hung like a horse and in response
to the review bombing an employee of the
ranch who also happens to be the owner's
son he makes a tick tock when you're not
a fat [__] you can ride a deep Hollow
Ranch and wow that is that is definitely
a response so of course that response
blows up and that's when traditional
news sources start picking up the store
thank you you know that's what we need
I'm tired of the simping Dave Dave you
gotta you gotta speak out about this
this is ridiculous these chicks honestly
I've seen Barstool I used to love bar
stool sports but since they brought in
so many women it's just the same [__] I
bet they get a lawsuit I bet you they
get a lawsuit in the next three years
for some sexual harassment blah blah
blah like I hear the Bree chick
complaining then I hear
um this chick complaining like I'm just
so done with all of the whining [__]
lose weight 240 pounds as fat as [__]
like that that is so fat like get on the
track I don't care what you got to do I
don't care if you starve yourself I
don't care if you get on the treadmill
but 240 is ridiculous you're gonna give
yourself a freaking heart attack so
instead of whining bitching to everyone
else about oh boo hoo boohoo I can't
ride a horse yeah because the horse is
gonna suffocate under your blubber
that's what's gonna happen is you're
you're literally gonna you're gonna kill
the horse because you're so fat lose
some weight and come back that's not the
ranch's fault that you're too fat to get
on the horse stop whining and crying and
any guy that co-signs this is an
absolute simp because he's not telling
you the truth and the truth is you got
to lose weight chica all right so and
this is why I mean what what standard of
woman would she be gold no silver no
bronze no it would be like way below
average one to ten this chicks or two
six or two I don't care what you guys
say about me I'm I'm not that this is
um but if you do want a gold standard
why
go overseas because you won't get in
America but speaking of gold guys do you
want to take control of your financial
future but you don't know where to start
Noble gold Investments understand
investing in Precious Metals may sound
confusing but honestly guys the team at
Noble gold Investments makes it easy
let's hear from the actual Noble gold
investment customers the staff answered
all of my questions and helped me every
step of the way no pressure sales
tactics just honest kind of securing my
future is less stressful thanks to Noble
Gold's expertise don't settle for
financial uncertainty you know they'll
suggest options and see if you can
diversify into gold and silver right now
Noble gold Investments is offering a
free five ounce America the Beautiful
coin for qualified accounts don't settle
for financial uncertainty Noble gold
Investments has an A plus rating with
the Better Business brew and countless
five stars wide awake go to
noblegoldinvestments.com that's
noblegoldinvestments.com the only goal
old company that I trust so I guess you
know I had I had a tick tock I made this
a while ago but it was me and I said you
know a lot of you guys are shitty wives
and I think we could see that a lot of
us are shitty wives because my
generation's not even making it down the
aisle and if we do we get divorced in
like seven years so who raised us shitty
wives now you know the women are are
commenting and tick-tocking they're
horror stories to me so here you know
what I'm a sympathetic gal let's let's
hear let's hear come here let's hear
everything I should have sympathy for
come on
let me give you some specific examples
straight from my comment section while
in excruciating pain from a kidney
infection my husband came to me to ask
if dinner would be ready by seven I told
him if he wants to cook it he proceeded
to make only himself eggs P.S we have
three children ages six and under
my mom was out of town and my dad
claimed to not know how to put on sheets
or start the dishwasher the day after I
came home from a C-section with a
catheter still in from a bladder repair
I was the one making dinner while my
husband was on his Xbox I was in the
hospital recovering from having cancer
removed from my body my ex-husband went
and played basketball our neighbor
talked him into visiting me at the
hospital because cancer he argued with
me about when I was coming home to take
care of the kids pregnant and bedridden
with hyperemesis gravadiram here haven't
been able to eat or drink for two weeks
constant ER trips and he had the nerve
to tell me the dishes need to be done
because he needed a fork to eat instead
of running the dishwasher himself he
bought disposable plastic ware the men
at my husband's job asked him why he's
taking two to three weeks off when I
give birth since there's nothing for you
to do anyways
my husband plays with my son when we're
around extended family and they all
think it's weird says something about
their husbands I planned shopped
decorated and cooked all the food for
our kids graduation party I asked my
husband for help and he decided to paint
the house four days after having my
Fallopian tubes removed I had to be bent
over the bathtub bathing our
two-year-old I asked him each day to do
it and he wouldn't my husband refused to
get out of bed and help me when I was
crying in pain in the bathtub during
labor I kept texting him he kept reading
the text and ignoring it then going back
to sleep my mom had to force me to allow
him to come see the birth my ex-husband
just leaving me to go to work because he
cashed in his vacation time instead of
saving it for the week after I gave
birth my ex decided that doing the kids
laundry and making the bed was too much
work so he made his half of the bed his
laundry and did his dishes never the
kids laundry or dishes or mine yeah he
made half the bed I was messy but since
the divorce I think he's realized that
kids their work you know what's funny
they think this is a w you guys are
making kids with these men
[Music]
did I make you open your legs to Loser
guys other thing is number two women
think chores are just like the epitome
of like they are a godsend for doing
chores [__] we have a dishwasher a
Roomba
we even have like one of those automatic
moppy things and the funny thing is um
have you guys ever changed a tire
most of them know I know and they always
get one [__] from Tick Tock that's like
I'm so I'm gonna show Pearl I can change
a tire
so stupid and so it's like do women do
more of the traditionally masculine
things and ask yourself a question guys
do more men know how to cook
than women nowadays I would argue yeah
do women typically know how to do the
traditionally masculine things
fixing something in the house
um one Telltale sign of a single woman
is the smoke detector is always going
off
um changing light bulbs
fixing Plumbing issues electric issues
you know women and this is this is what
I want to show you guys men have given
us the freest most safest Society where
we can choose to do anything
and yet women still choose to make
children with losers I mean this isn't
if your ex didn't want to be there for
the birth of your kids I I have a
question one oh what's wrong with you
that he didn't want to be there for the
birth of your kid like it's always
everybody else you know really you have
no character flaws all of these women
had no character flaws they were just so
amazing and perfect and it was just the
evil man so either a you make children
with evil men
that's on you
um or two you're just narcissistic and
you think that anything that you do is
God's gift to the Earth and you don't
appreciate the things that the people
are doing for you around you and your
bitcher and whiner and complainer and
just like to moan
and I just I just can't stand it so yeah
you guys um got me yeah you you make
kids with losers
I I can't make this [__] up I literally
can't
um
okay last last story today so um I talk
a lot about the women that are age maybe
40 to 60. that really just raised like
the worst generation of women ever they
did I mean they did not teach us how to
be wives most of them don't believe in
submitting to their husband's Authority
most of them are overweight and most of
them really have issues and you know I
mean most people have issues my
generation is no better but
I'll tell you I call them the generation
of shitty wives for a reason so Jeannie
Mae and Jeezy
um actually were married about two years
ago now now Jeannie Mae has historically
never wanted children and she was
married to another guy for about 10
years
um and she was married to another guy
for 10 years and did not want kids with
him then you know she gets engaged and
marries a world Superstar and magically
she wants children how how crazy is that
but they did get married and honestly
guys they I thought they were such a
cute couple I mean Genie went on TV and
talked about she wanted to submit to his
authority but in my opinion it sort of
looks like her anger issues that she's
admitted to really have gotten the best
of her so let's pull the clip
it's over Virginia Mai and Jeezy the TV
personality and the rapper are divorcing
two years after saying I do Access
Hollywood has learned according to legal
documents obtained by NBC News Jeezy
filed paperwork on September 14th to end
his ingenious marriage and is requesting
joint custody of their 20-month-old
daughter Monaco aprina is in place
access has reached out to both parties
for comment the couple tied the knot in
March 2021 in an intimate ceremony at
their Georgia home and Jeannie
previously explained how pandemic
restrictions and personal loss shifted
their original plan to Wed in the south
of France telling Vogue at the time
after Jeezy's mother unexpectedly passed
we quickly learned that life is too
short and at the end of the day Jeezy
and I really just wanted to become
husband and wife so we decided to turn
our original wedding into a mini-money
where we exchanged our vows in front of
our immediate family and a few close
friends I have a really hot temper not a
lot of people know this but it's just
something in my family I've seen it my
grandmother I'm sorry I saw in my
grandfather to my grandmother to my mom
to my aunts to me right but I didn't
notice it in myself until I was with
Jeezy interesting you didn't notice in
your previous marriage no no because I
because
it has to do with the type of
relationship you have and the type of
respect you have for that person to
mirror things back to you where you
actually would stop you in your tracks
end evaluate yourself you know so you
had it so I had it but nobody ever
nobody ever called me out on it also in
my line of work sometimes being a boss
isn't so
isn't so great for you because you have
a lot of people who just agree to what
you want they're Yes Men right and so I
did notice that I had a hot temper until
I got with Jeezy yeah so here Jeannie is
talking about how you know
she's never been checked on anger her
anger her temper before and as women do
we blame the we take the accountability
and put it on the family whatever and
you know with a guy like Jeezy who has
all the leverage this shit's just not
gonna fly it's not gonna work and
um unfortunately this is why guys like
younger women you know I mean what are
her odds of changing a habit she's had
for uh 40 years
I mean guys that's a long time the
second thing was they met in covid and I
just think a lot of people that had
their relationships start in covid I
just don't really see lasting for the
Long Haul so Jeannie um posted on
Instagram she said today I celebrate a
remarkable Milestone achieved by my
husband Jeezy whose Memoir adversity for
sale has soared to the New York Times
bestsellers list your story has always
been an inspiration to me but seeing it
in print has left me even more in awe of
your strength and wisdom you invited us
into the most intimate corners of your
life where pain and Triumph coexist this
moment isn't just a testament to your
literary skills baby but a recognition
of your ability to inspire through the
power of Storytelling I'm endlessly
grateful for your voice in the world
honored to walk beside you love and you
can see in the comments section anavona
says this is so odd how she posted this
a week ago and then he files commented
on here with the heart damn Genie I'm
sorry and you know Jesus is kind of a
Savage I gotta be honest guys he posts
this I'm too focused on who I'm becoming
to focus on who's not coming with me
yeah guys so I just I I think it goes to
show this is why guys kind of tend to
pick younger chicks I mean uh at 40 a
woman that has never really wanted kids
isn't really gonna have the motherly
instincts you're looking for and not and
I mean let's just be honest guys I don't
know if really world-renowned Superstars
typically make the best husbands I don't
know if they're all meant for like a
more traditional life so it'll be
interesting to see how this plays out
um see he had a prenup which is a good
thing we're pro prenups here yeah and
this is really a lesson to the younger
women that if you have anger issues that
shit's not gonna fly you can't you can
only get away with that with a guy you
don't respect and and you see Jeannie
divorced her first husband it was a guy
that never checked her and then she got
divorced by a guy that checked her
probably because she couldn't handle her
anchor issues but let me know in the
comments on what you guys think uh make
sure you like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time